Jake:那天晚上
Jake: That night
Alice: 哪天晚上
Alice: Which night?
刘婷:我们认识那天晚上
Liu Ting: The night we met
Tasha:第一个爱情的晚上
Tasha: The first night of love
Alice: 哇靠
Alice: Wow
Alice: 恶心
Alice: Gross
Jake: 闭环了呗
Jake: It's all connected
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Alice: 受不了了
Alice: I can't stand it
Jake: 再来一个
Jake: Let's have another one
Jake: 这么不爱吃饭
Jake: Why don't you like eating?
Jake: 你把吃馄饨蘸上呗
Jake: Just dip the wonton
刘婷:辣椒油
Liu Ting: In chili oil
Jake: 哦咱没有是吧
Jake: Oh, we don't have any, right?
Tasha:不用了
Tasha: No need
Jake: 呃要可以要
Jake: Uh, if you want, you can have it
Alice: 我要辣椒面
Alice: I want chili powder
Jake: 对我们好像有存货
Jake: Yeah, I think we have some in stock
Jake: 辣椒油
Jake: Chili oil
Alice:我们还有白芝麻
Alice: We also have white sesame
Tasha:辣椒油还有
Tasha: There's still chili oil
Jake:那有
Jake: There is
Tasha:咦 哇靠
Tasha: Ew, wow
Jake: 我上去找找
Jake: I'll go look for it
Jake: 我记得有那种小辣包
Jake: I remember we have those small chili packs
Alice: 你就编吧
Alice: Just make it up
刘婷:你就说
Liu Ting: Just say it
Alice: 编
Alice: Make it up
刘婷:这个红色
Liu Ting: This red
刘婷:马甲就是这个
Liu Ting: Vest, this is it
Alice: 编
Alice: Make it up
刘婷:什么什么就是编呢本来就是
Liu Ting: What do you mean, make it up? It really is
Alice:  你放屁
Alice: You're talking nonsense
Alice: 不是这样的
Alice: It's not like that
刘婷:是这样的
Liu Ting: It is like that
Alice:不是这样的
Alice: It's not like that
Alice:你给我拿证据
Alice: Show me the evidence
刘婷:你给我拿证据
Liu Ting: Show me the evidence
Alice:你给我拿证据
Alice: Show me the evidence
Alice: 你自己非要问这个问题了
Alice: You're the one who asked this question
刘婷:嗯
Liu Ting: Hmm
刘婷:就是这件
Liu Ting: It's this one.
Alice: 不是这件
Alice: No, it's not this one.
刘婷:决对是
Liu Ting: It definitely is.
Alice: 不是这件
Alice: No, it's not.
刘婷:哇哇怎么怎么有人这么爱穿红色
Liu Ting: Wow wow, how can someone love wearing red so much?
刘婷:绝对是
Liu Ting: It definitely is.
Alice: 不是
Alice: No, it's not.
刘婷:那是什么
Liu Ting: Then what is it?
Alice: 那我们那天什么颜色眼影
Alice: What color eyeshadow were we wearing that day?
Alice: 什么颜色眼影
Alice: What color eyeshadow?
Alice: 哼哼
Alice: Hmm hmm.
Alice: 滚
Alice: Go away.
Alice: 我第一天见你的时候你穿的裤子
Alice: The pants you wore the first day I met you.
Alice: 哈哈哈没有啊
Alice: Hahaha, no, not at all.
Alice: 那我是不是说对了
Alice: Did I get it right?
Alice: 我现在也是
Alice: Me too, right now.
Alice: 赏花去吧
Alice: Let's go enjoy the flowers.
Alice: 一天啊
Alice: All day, huh?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 行吗
Alice: Okay?
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Alice: 他带了GPS
Alice: He brought a GPS.
Jake: 外形高等文明
Jake: Advanced civilization.
Alice: 放胡椒粉了
Alice: Added pepper.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake: 我不要啊
Jake: I don't want it.
Jake: 也可以要啊
Jake: Or maybe I do.
Jake: 不要了不要了
Jake: Nevermind, nevermind.
Jake: 问候一下问候一下家人们
Jake: Say hi, say hi to the family.
Alice: 干嘛 刚刚聊天
Alice: What? Just chatting.
刘婷:我一朋友他
Liu Ting: A friend of mine,
刘婷:最近为情所困
Liu Ting: He's troubled by love recently.
Jake: 吾友亦友啊
Jake: My friend too.
刘婷:啊对我是对我是他朋友
Liu Ting: Yeah, he's my friend too.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 那个人不是你吧
Alice: That person isn't you, right?
Alice: 不像是你
Alice: Doesn't seem like you.
Alice: 天天没心没肺的
Alice: Always carefree.
刘婷:神经病吧你
Liu Ting: Are you crazy?
刘婷:用的排除法你知道吗
Liu Ting: You know, I used the method of elimination.
Alice: 你不以前不告诉我你家有这样的别墅
Alice: Why didn't you tell me you had a villa like this before?
刘婷:你没问啊
Liu Ting: You didn't ask.
刘婷:你也没对我多好啊
Liu Ting: You weren't that nice to me either.
Alice: 那我喂你吃饭
Alice: But I fed you.
刘婷:我吃完了
Liu Ting: I'm done eating.
Alice: 你还吃吗
Alice: Do you want more?
刘婷:我不吃
Liu Ting: No, I'm good.
Alice: Lucia她们怎么样了
Alice: How are Lucia and the others?
Jake: 我在问
Jake: I'm asking.
刘婷:她们生病了吗
Liu Ting: Are they sick?
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice: 那不然刚刚
Alice: Otherwise, just now...
Alice: 刚刚跟你说了
Alice: Just now, I told you...
Alice: 有人要去医院让你把道让开
Alice: Someone needs to go to the hospital, so let them through.
Alice: 我骗你的吗
Alice: Am I lying to you?
Jake: 你不是去医院抢救
Jake: You're not going to the hospital for emergency?
刘婷:啊
Liu Ting: Ah.
Jake: 去医院干啥去了
Jake: What are you going to the hospital for?
Jake: 没有没有不是
Jake: No, no, no, it's not...
Alice:Lucia旁边的浅头发女孩
Alice: The blonde girl next to Lucia...
刘婷:我的天呢
Liu Ting: Oh my gosh.
Alice: 不然为什么会突然说肠胃炎
Alice: Why else would they suddenly say gastroenteritis?
Alice: 对啊那不就是吗
Alice: Yeah, isn't that it?
刘婷:哦现实的朋友哦
Liu Ting: Oh, real friends, huh?
Jake: 嗯哼 吾有一友
Jake: Mm-hmm, I have a friend...
Alice:绝了
Alice: Unbelievable.
Jake: 这个确实
Jake: This is indeed...
Jake: AI可能做的会强一点
Jake: AI might be better at this.
Jake: 哈哈在这件事上
Jake: Haha, in this matter.
刘婷:打算什么时候走
Liu Ting: When do you plan to leave?
Alice: 再把那个东西再装到
Alice: After we pack that thing...
Alice: 装完装完收拾下我们就走吧
Alice: Once we finish packing, we'll leave.
Alice: 杨老板我们走之前这个你需要拆吗
Alice: Jake, do you need to dismantle this before we leave?
Jake: 嗯我看一下啊
Jake: Let me take a look.
Alice: 给你拆了我们再走吧
Alice: We'll leave after you dismantle it.
Jake: 嗯嗯看下它还能录多久
Jake: Hmm, let's see how much longer it can record.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Damn.
Jake: 稍等
Jake: Hold on.
Alice: 有何吩咐
Alice: Any instructions?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake: 嗯看一下
Jake: Hmm, take a look.
Alice: 留个纪念吧
Alice: Let's take a picture to remember this.
Alice: 哎我手机呢
Alice: Hey, where's my phone?
Alice: 我又不跟他合影
Alice: I'm not taking a picture with him.
Alice: 我就拍他就可以了
Alice: I'll just take a picture of him.
Alice: 背景是不是有点乱
Alice: Is the background a bit messy?
Alice: 确实有点乱这样吧
Alice: It really is a bit messy, let's do this.
刘婷:但是你谁摄影技术弥补了这一不足
Liu Ting: But your photography skills make up for it.
Alice: 你嘴真甜
Alice: You're so sweet.
Alice: 我真喜欢你
Alice: I really like you.
Alice: 需要拆吗
Alice: Do we need to take it apart?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
刘婷:时刻准备着
Liu Ting: Always ready.
Jake: 拆吧呃
Jake: Take it apart.
Jake: 我要先把它关机
Jake: I need to turn it off first.
Alice: 来吧婷
Alice: Come on, Ting.
Alice: 没事先挂着吧
Alice: It's fine, just hang it up first.
刘婷:走的时候记得换鞋啊
Liu Ting: Remember to change your shoes before you leave.
Alice: 我现在换
Alice: I'll change them now.
Alice: 你不也没换鞋你说我
Alice: You didn't change your shoes either, and you're telling me to?
刘婷:我不着急
Liu Ting: I'm not in a hurry.
Alice: 老板把它关了吗
Alice: Boss, did you turn it off?
Jake: 都关了OK
Jake: It's all off, OK.
Alice: 拆
Alice: Take it apart.
Alice: 你你去拆那个高的
Alice: You, go take apart the tall one.
Alice: 那个危险
Alice: That one's dangerous.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
刘婷:谢谢你哈
Liu Ting: Thank you.
Jake: 对这还是柯欣
Jake: Yes, this is still from Kesin.
Jake: 这亲手
Jake: This is handmade.
Alice:还是我亲手粘上的
Alice: I glued it myself.
Jake:对亲手钉的线
Jake: Yes, you sewed it by hand.
Alice: 那就好好告个别吧
Alice: Then let's say a proper goodbye.
Alice: 然后什么哪个BGM
Alice: And what about the BGM?
Alice: 就是这个就是这个啊
Alice: This one, this one.
Alice: 你一般那个弄不下来
Alice: You usually can't get that one down.
Alice: 你就你先把那个啥给卷下来
Alice: Just roll that thing down first.
Alice: 不不不你把那个摄像头给弄下来
Alice: No, no, take the camera down first.
Alice: 能听懂我的话吧
Alice: Can you understand what I'm saying?
Alice: 我对你的智力是没有怀疑的
Alice: I don't doubt your intelligence at all.
Alice: 易如反掌
Alice: Piece of cake.
Jake: 反掌
Jake: Cake.
Alice: 易如反掌
Alice: Piece of cake.
Jake:  掌
Jake: Cake.
Alice:掌
Alice: Cake.
Alice: 刘婷你一来我说脏话的频率
Alice: Liu Ting, since you came, I've been swearing more.
刘婷:这不应该怪你啊
Liu Ting: That's not your fault.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
刘婷:不这怎么还有个贴纸呢
Liu Ting: Why is there a sticker here?
刘婷:我草
Liu Ting: Damn.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 拆了就放桌上
Jake: Just put it on the table after you take it apart.
Jake:哎这个给我吧
Jake: Hey, give that to me.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Alice: 哎这怎么还粘了一个
Alice: Hey, why is there another one stuck here?
Jake:这这柯欣布线
Jake: This is special wiring by Kexin.
Jake: 特别的
Jake: It's unique.
Jake: 我怎么了
Jake: What's up with me?
Jake: 特别的实在这布线
Jake: This wiring is truly special.
刘婷:明枪易躲暗剑难防唉
Liu Ting: Open attacks are easy to dodge, hidden ones are hard to guard against.
Alice: 刘婷我给你变个魔术吧
Alice: Liu Ting, let me show you a magic trick.
刘婷:你不能变
Liu Ting: You can't do magic.
Alice: 我非要变呢
Alice: But I really want to show you.
Alice: 哈哈我给你变一个
Alice: Haha, I'll show you one.
Alice: 我跟你说
Alice: Let me tell you.
Alice: 这桌子底下果然没有人发现
Alice: No one noticed under the table.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:你看这是啥
Alice: Look, what's this?
刘婷:谁躺在桌子底下看啊
Liu Ting: Who looks under the table?
Jake: 藏的确实挺好
Jake: It's really well hidden.
Alice: 没有人发现
Alice: No one noticed.
刘婷:就是你干的好事
Liu Ting: It's your doing.
Alice: 我每天都在干好事
Alice: I do good deeds every day.
Alice: 下一个你把这低的留给我
Alice: Next time, leave the low one for me.
Alice: 你去看你去
Alice: You go check it out.
Alice: 摄像头好烫啊
Alice: The camera is so hot.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Alice:它已经连续工作好几天了
Alice: It's been working continuously for several days.
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 每天都会重启的
Jake: It restarts every day.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 上班了
Alice: Time to work.
Alice: ego nife一勾
Alice: Ego knife, just one slice.
Alice: 哎哟贴这么黏实干嘛
Alice: Why did you stick it so firmly?
刘婷:哎呀
Liu Ting: Oh no.
Jake: 不黏可不行
Jake: It has to be firm.
Alice: 干嘛刘婷
Alice: What's up, Liu Ting?
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
刘婷:粘的太牢了
Liu Ting: It's stuck too tightly.
Alice: 干活比较细致
Alice: Gotta be meticulous with the work.
刘婷:从来 唉哟我的妈呀
Liu Ting: Never do shoddy work.
刘婷:从来不做豆腐渣工程
刘婷:你说呀后来干啥
Liu Ting: So, what happened later?
Alice: 不是这衣服
Alice: Not this outfit.
Alice: 你死不死 我不知道
Alice: Whether you die or not, I don't know.
刘婷:那是什么呢
Liu Ting: What is it then?
刘婷:你看吗
Liu Ting: Are you looking?
Alice: 那我反正不是这个
Alice: Well, it's definitely not this one.
刘婷:在你手上你不举证我说了也
Liu Ting: It's in your hand, if you don't show evidence...
Alice: 那我看一下我那天有没有拍照准备
Alice: Let me check if I took any pictures that day.
Alice: 再说吧
Alice: We'll talk about it later.
Alice: 到时候再看
Alice: We'll see later.
Alice: 还有呢
Alice: What else?
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Alice:那个危险的就你来吧
Alice: You handle the dangerous part.
Jake: 那个那个我来搞吧
Jake: I'll take care of that.
Jake: 刘停 哎对摸不上就算 不
Jake: Liu Ting, if you can't touch it, then forget it.
Jake: 那那那我来搞吧
Jake: Let me handle it.
Jake: 那你们
Jake: You all...
Alice:这个这个
Alice: This, this...
Jake:太危险了
Jake: Too dangerous.
Alice: 易如反掌
Alice: Piece of cake.
Jake: 易如反掌
Jake: Piece of cake.
刘婷:操作一下
Liu Ting: Give it a try.
Alice: 人生易如反掌啊
Alice: Life's a piece of cake.
Alice: 你咋不反掌了
Alice: Why aren't you flipping your hand?
Alice: 倒反天罡了是吗
Alice: Are you reversing the heavens?
Katrina:  就是昨天XBZ放桌上的那个头孢
Katrina: It's the cefalexin that XBZ left on the table yesterday.
Katrina:  还在吗
Katrina: Are you still there?
Jake:  呃我找找啊
Jake: Uh, let me look for it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 找到了吗
Katrina: Did you find it?
Jake: 我 靠这东西上哪找去 好
Jake: Damn, where can I find this thing? Okay.
Jake: 你们记得这个头孢在什么地方吗
Jake: Do you guys remember where the cephalosporin is?
Jake: 你们收拾了吗
Jake: Did you guys put it away?
刘婷:拿走吃了吧
Liu Ting: Just take it and eat it.
刘婷:是不是在二楼冰箱上
Liu Ting: Is it on the fridge on the second floor?
Jake: 找找啊找找看
Jake: Look for it, look around.
刘婷:让那个黄头发的小哥拿走了
Liu Ting: The blonde guy took it.
Katrina: 我能喝水吗他们跟我说不要喝
Katrina: Can I drink water? They told me not to.
刘婷:取得下来不
Liu Ting: Can you take it down?
Jake: 等一下我上二楼看看啊
Jake: Wait, I'll go check the second floor.
Jake:有健胃消食片 头饱
Jake: There's digestive tablets and cephalosporin.
Jake:布洛芬 我靠
Jake: Ibuprofen, damn.
Katrina: 在一楼的桌子上我记得
Katrina: I remember it being on the table on the first floor.
Jake:就你房间那
Jake: In your room?
Jake:那我在看看去
Jake: Then I'll check again.
嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 柯欣来找找吧
Jake: Ke Xin, come help look for it.
Jake: 要不帮忙
Jake: Or help out.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah?
Alice:药
Alice: Medicine?
Jake: 对找找那头孢
Jake: Yeah, look for the cephalosporin.
Alice: 找那个头孢
Alice: Look for the cephalosporin.
Alice: 是要看他之前吃的什么药是吗
Alice: You want to see what medicine he took before, right?
Jake: 不是不是就是就是
Jake: No, no, just, just...
Jake: 找头孢就是找到了
Jake: Just find the cephalosporin and that's it.
Jake: 就就就能吃是吗
Jake: Then, then he can take it, right?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 那我自己买一盒在医生这开一个
Katrina: Then I'll buy a box myself and get a prescription from the doctor.
Jake: 行行行
Jake: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 好拜拜
Katrina: Okay, bye-bye.
Jake: 好拜拜
Jake: Okay, bye-bye.
Alice: 重新买吗
Alice: Buy it again?
Jake: 可以买
Jake: You can buy it.
刘婷:你 能行吗 拔半天了
Liu Ting: Can you do it? You've been pulling for ages.
Alice: 我要梯子干嘛
Alice: Why do I need a ladder?
Alice: 我能够着不是
Alice: I can reach it, can't I?
刘婷:拨不下来的兄弟
Tina: Can't get it off, bro.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh man.
Alice: 不好意思
Alice: Sorry.
Alice: 让你失望
Alice: Didn't mean to let you down.
Alice: 这还能用第二次吗
Alice: Can we use this a second time?
Jake: 不那当然
Jake: No, of course not.
Jake: 不管它有没有价值
Jake: Whether it's valuable or not.
Jake: 只是不在我们的考虑范围内
Jake: It's just not in our consideration.
Alice: 就这吧拆下来拿走
Alice: Let's just take this apart and go.
Alice: 下一个
Alice: Next one.
Alice:我咋啦
Alice: What happened to me?
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Alice: 这个太光滑了
Alice: This is too smooth.
Alice: 丝滑无痛
Alice: Silky smooth, no pain.
Alice: 没了吧
Alice: Is that it?
Alice: 还有冰箱啊这个
Alice: There's still the fridge, right?
Alice: 啊不是冰箱空调
Alice: Ah no, it's the air conditioner.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Tina.
Alice: 你干嘛呢
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice: 你以为呢
Alice: What do you think?
Alice: 没有了好像
Alice: Seems like there's nothing left.
Alice: 这个门上的这个也是我们的吗
Alice: Is this thing on the door also ours?
Jake:  这不是
Jake: No, it's not.
Jake: 这是窗帘
Jake: It's a curtain.
Alice:嗯这上面还有一个
Alice: Hmm, there's another one up here.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 我靠这这么响
Jake: Whoa, that's loud.
Jake: 确实就只要劲大他就能弄下来
Jake: Yeah, if you use enough force, it will come off.
Alice: 这是我们的东西吗
Alice: Is this our stuff?
Jake: 我靠这不是
Jake: Whoa, it's not.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们就贴了一个那个夹子
Jake: Haha, we just stuck that clip on.
Alice: 那我再把它给
Alice: Then I'll just...
Jake: 哈哈哈这东西弄下来得赔钱啊
Jake: Haha, taking this down will cost money.
Jake: 哈哈哈估计
Jake: Haha, I guess.
Alice: 我来吧
Alice: Let me do it.
Alice: 哇哦你好man
Alice: Wow, you're so manly.
Alice: 你好牛
Alice: You're so cool.
Alice: 帅的嘞
Alice: That's awesome.
Alice: 这个如果弄不下来的话是不是也要
Alice: If we can't get this off, does it mean we...
Jake: 不知道这问一下别墅
Jake: I don't know, better ask
Alice: 用风油精或者啥的
Alice: Use some essential oil or something.
Alice: 然后拿电风扇吹一吹就好弄
Alice: Then blow it with a fan, it’ll be easier to handle.
Alice: 风油精那种油的东西
Alice: Essential oil, that kind of oily stuff.
Alice: 好准备走吧
Alice: Alright, get ready to go.
Alice:最后一步
Alice: Last step.
Alice:拿上吧
Alice: Take it.
Alice:拿着吧赏你了
Alice: Hold onto it, it's for you.
Jake: 哎屋子里有伞吗
Jake: Hey, is there an umbrella in the house?
Jake: 薇薇好像跑出去玩了
Jake: Seems like Tasha went out to play.
Jake: 回不来
Jake: She can't come back.
Jake: 就是雨太大了
Jake: It’s just raining too hard.
Jake: 你在哪呢
Jake: Where are you?
Jake: where are you
刘婷:啊我有我有
Liu Ting: Ah, I have one, I have one.
Alice: 呜呜呜我去
Alice: Oh my gosh!
Alice: 不是我以为这有个那个小棚
Alice: I thought there was a small shelter here.
Alice: 这
Alice: This...
Jake: 好搞笑啊
Jake: So funny.
Alice: 这怎么走呢
Alice: How do we get there?
Jake: 等等伞呢他
Jake: Wait, the umbrella...
Jake: 你把这个伞直接拔下来
Jake: Just take the umbrella off.
Alice:哈哈哈你爹
Alice: Hahaha, your dad...
Alice: 来去接她哈哈哈
Alice: Let's go pick her up, hahaha.
刘婷:来啦来啦来啦
Liu Ting: Coming, coming, coming.
Alice: 你的骑士来了
Alice: Your knight is here.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 当当当当哈哈哈
Alice: Ta-da-da-da, hahaha.
Alice: 她俩啊她俩拿伞了
Alice: They’ve got an umbrella.
Jake: 她俩怪惨的
Jake: They look so miserable.
刘婷:拿行礼箱去吧
Liu Ting: Let’s take the suitcase.
Alice: 走
Alice: Let’s go.
Tasha:这雨好大哦你们要走了是吧
Tasha: The rain is so heavy, are you leaving?
Alice: 对对对
Alice: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
刘婷:对对对
Liu Ting: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice: 虽然这个也不怎么下
Alice: Even though this isn’t much.
Alice: 嗯那个更不能
Alice: Hmm, that’s even less.
Alice: 那个是毛毛的
Alice: That one’s just a drizzle.
刘婷:算了
Liu Ting: Forget it.
Alice: 什么算了
Alice: What do you mean forget it?
Alice: 算什么
Alice: Forget what?
Alice: 哎今天你要不跟我一块走
Alice: Hey, why don't you come with me today?
Alice: 我还走不了了呢
Alice: I can't leave yet.
Alice: 是不
Alice: Right?
Alice: 是吧
Jake: 什么时候出去的
Jake: When did you go out?
Jake:哦 那你呆了好久
Jake: Oh, you've been there for a while.
Alice: 对啊我手机呢
Alice: Yeah, where's my phone?
Alice: 啊呀
Alice: Ah, come on.
Alice:我们准备走吧
Alice: Let's get going.
Alice: 哼停止录制
Alice: Stop recording.
Alice:去西阳
Alice: Let's go to Xiyang.
Jake: 去
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha:这雨挺大的回不来了
Tasha: The rain is so heavy, we can't come back.
Jake: 对去吸氧
Jake: Yeah, let's go get some oxygen.
Jake: 吸把人吸回不来
Jake: Get so much oxygen you can't come back.
Tasha: 老板老板给你了
Tasha: Boss, boss, here you go.
Jake:接 接
Jake: Got it, got it.
Jake: 哦谢谢
Jake: Oh, thanks.
刘婷:我说我走你别拿 伞啊
Liu Ting: I said I'll go, don't take the umbrella.
Alice:我还没收拾完呢
Alice: I haven't finished packing yet.
Jake: 哈哈那来
Jake: Haha, come on.
Jake: 那来搞一搞吧
Jake: Let's get to work.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 她们说这个得自己处理好
Jake: They said we have to handle this ourselves.
Jake: 所以吹风机吹吹
Jake: So, use a hair dryer.
Jake: 能有用吗
Jake: Will that work?
Jake: 嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 用洗衣液先把它涂一圈
Tasha: Use laundry detergent to coat it first.
Tasha: 然后吹风机吹吹
Tasha: Then use the hair dryer.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Jake: 呵抹挺好啊
Jake: Wow, it's looking good.
Tasha: 把上面的也抹一抹
Tasha: Wipe the top part too.
Tasha: 擦不掉嘛
Tasha: Can't wipe it off?
Jake:能擦掉 好
Jake: It can be wiped off, okay.
Tasha: 这个用酒精擦掉 好
Tasha: Use alcohol to wipe it off, okay.
Tasha: 你把每个都涂上
Tasha: Coat each one.
Tasha: 然后从第一个再开始吹好
Tasha: Then start drying from the first one, okay.
Jake: 还得是您
Jake: You're the best.
Jake:哎哟
Jake: Ouch
Jake:拆下来
Jake: Take it down
Tasha:他们明天来吗
Tasha: Are they coming tomorrow?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 他们明天来有啥用
Jake: What's the point of them coming tomorrow?
Jake: 都干完了
Jake: It's all done
Jake:  哈哈哈明天来咱就纯聊天了
Jake: Hahaha, if they come tomorrow, we'll just be chatting
Tasha:哦靠
Tasha: Oh, damn
Jake: 你明天什么答辩
Jake: What presentation do you have tomorrow?
Tasha:汇报
Tasha: Report
Jake: 汇报上课是吗
Jake: Report, is it a class?
Jake: 什么上什么课呀什么课呀
Jake: What class is it, what class?
Tasha:就是最后一次课了汇报
Tasha: It's the last class, a report
Jake: 什么课呀
Jake: What class is it?
Jake: 哦那就是那
Jake: Oh, it's that
Tasha:设计作品还没做呢
Tasha: I haven't done the design work yet
Jake: 我给你做我给你做
Jake: I'll do it for you, I'll do it
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Alice:这个是不是要我们自己清
Alice: Do we have to clean this ourselves?
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, we do
Alice:看见清一下
Alice: Make sure to clean it
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes
Alice:最好用卸妆膏
Alice: It's best to use cleansing balm
Tasha: 哦对我有卸妆膏
Tasha: Oh right, I have cleansing balm
Tasha:这洗衣液
Tasha: This laundry detergent
Jake:哈哈 卸妆膏祛这个  可以是吗
Jake: Haha, cleansing balm can remove this? Really?
Tasha:卸妆膏不是油
Tasha: Cleansing balm isn't oily
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha:都打车回去去报销
Jake: 都报销
Jake: Everything gets reimbursed
Tasha:我明天回学校也可以报
Tasha: I can also get reimbursed at school tomorrow
Jake: 那当然啦
Jake: Of course
Alice:啊可以报销
Alice: Ah, it can be reimbursed
Tasha:打车报销
Tasha: Taxi fare reimbursement
Jake: 就嗯对
Jake: Yeah, that's right
Alice:收拾好了吗
Alice: Are you done packing?
刘婷:早收拾好了
Choiszt: Finished long ago
Jake: 你吹走了
Jake: You blew it away
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake:是你吹走了这个数字
Jake: You blew this number away.
Jake:嗨
Jake: Hi.
Jake: 这边还有这上面这
Jake: There's still some here, and on top.
Jake: 这上面还有一个
Jake: There's one more on top.
Jake:这上面还没弄下来
Jake: Haven't got this one down yet.
Jake: 那就好弄这最好弄
Jake: This one's easy to get, the easiest.
Tasha:这今天没人帮你干活
Tasha: Nobody's helping you today?
Tasha:你就不能等些谢彬竹来了
Tasha: Can't you wait for Xie Binzhu to come?
Tasha:再继续干这个活吗
Tasha: And then continue this work?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:没有恶意
Tasha: No offense.
Tasha:哈哈哈你看你一个人干完了
Tasha: Haha, you did it all by yourself.
Tasha:这多不好呀
Tasha: Isn't that bad?
Jake:那让他来清这个
Jake: Let him clean this up.
好Tasha:
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我就不给他抹了
Jake: I won't wipe it for him.
Jake:让他从头开始
Jake: Let him start from scratch.
Jake:那这个还抹吗
Jake:这个不给他抹
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
人呢没来
Unknown: The person didn't come.
活已经安排上了
Unknown: The work's already assigned.
Jake: 对然后我们先吹两个意思一下
Jake: Right, let's blow two first to symbolize.
那我们先吹两个意思一下
Unknown: Let's blow two first to symbolize.
哈哈对
Unknown: Haha, right.
Jake: 啊对我们先不测一下
Jake: Ah, let's not test it first.
我们测一下
Unknown: Let's test it.
Jake: 应该也是
Jake: It should be...
应该也试试
Unknown: It should be tested too.
Jake: 楼上有 呃 这个就这个插排吧
Jake: Upstairs there's, uh, this power strip.
Jake:这个插排好
Jake: This power strip is good.
Tasha:好你就先把这个测试一下吧
Tasha: Alright, test this one first.
Tasha:先用第一个吧
Tasha: Use the first one.
Jake: 太太高了
Jake: It's too high.
Jake: 嗯这个抹了对吧
Jake: Hmm, this one's wiped, right?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 这边底下有
Jake: There's some underneath here.
Katrina: hello
Katrina: Hello.
Jake:hello 还好吗
Jake: Hello, how are you?
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 淋雨了吗
Jake: Did you get caught in the rain?
Jake: 怎么回来的呀
Jake: How did you get back?
Lucia:给您一个雨中的视频
Lucia: I'll send you a video in the rain.
Jake: 我去 谢谢你
Jake: Oh, thank you.
我去谢谢你
Lucia:我去我刚给你发的语音信息
Lucia: Oh, I just sent you a voice message.
Lucia:一直都没发出来
Lucia: It didn't go through.
Lucia:老天爷好吧
Lucia: Oh well, never mind.
刘婷:sorry
Liu Ting: Sorry.
Tasha:我们把那个铲铲拿下来吧
Tasha: Let's take that shovel down.
Jake: 金铲铲
Jake: The golden shovel.
Jake: 有用然后呢
Jake: It's useful, and then?
Alice:你用热吗
Alice: Do you feel hot?
Jake:它整么调啊
Jake: How do you adjust it?
他怎么调啊我我我
Jake: How do you adjust it, I, I...
Alice:热了
Alice: It's hot.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Alice:这是风力
Alice: This is the wind speed.
Jake: 风力啊
Jake: Wind speed, huh?
Jake: 那个最强
Jake: Which one is the strongest?
Alice:啊最大的了
Alice: Ah, this is the maximum.
Jake: 我试试我试试
Jake: Let me try it, let me try it.
Jake: 我来用手徒手试试
Jake: I'll try it with my hand.
Jake: 这谁知道行不行
Jake: Who knows if this will work.
Jake: 飞了一个
Jake: One flew off.
Tasha: 很好
Tasha: Good.
Tasha: 只需要耐心就可以完成这项任务
Tasha: You just need patience to complete this task.
Jake: 还是要铲是吧
Jake: Still need the shovel, right?
Jake: 耐心不足这是
Jake: This is a lack of patience.
Tasha: 感觉跟瓦匠一样
Tasha: Feels like being a mason.
Jake: 瓦匠可比这轻松多了我靠
Jake: Being a mason is much easier than this, damn.
Tasha: 真的不能让房东干吗
Tasha: Can't we let the landlord do it?
Tasha: 这去一个得半个小时
Tasha: It takes half an hour for just one.
Tasha: 别墅给我去完一天
Tasha: It would take me a whole day to finish a villa.
Jake: 我靠怎么这么多啊
Jake: Damn, why are there so many?
Jake: 怎么这么多纸
Jake: Why so much paper?
Katrina:  就是抽了个写了个发票
Katrina: Just pulled out and wrote an invoice.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 就是肠胃炎
Jake: It's gastroenteritis.
Katrina:  就是就是
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  细菌性肠胃炎
Katrina: Bacterial gastroenteritis.
Katrina:  咱吃都吃不干净
Katrina: We eat stuff that's not clean.
Jake: 昨天看你吃的什么
Jake: What did I see you eating yesterday?
Jake: 我们没吃的东西是吧
Jake: Stuff we didn't eat, right?
Jake: 呵呵呵你偷吃
Jake: Haha, you sneaked some food.
Jake: 啥了
Jake: What was it?
Lucia:大家好像都吃过了
Lucia: Seems like everyone ate it.
Jake: 你偷吃啥
Jake: What did you sneak?
Jake: 没关系我们都有监控
Jake: No worries, we have cameras.
Jake: 你这个眼镜实验室
Jake: Your glasses lab.
Jake: 哈哈哈你眼镜戴的
Jake: Haha, your glasses.
Jake: 实验这个就是一个好问题
Jake: This experiment is a good one.
Katrina:  罪魁祸首是谁
Katrina: Who's the culprit?
Jake: 对你要不你戴个眼镜把这段录下去
Jake: Yeah, maybe wear some glasses and record this part.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 对闭环闭环
Jake: Yeah, a closed loop.
Jake: 太妙了呀
Jake: So clever.
Lucia: 在那个卫生所里
Lucia: At that health clinic.
Jake: 我没录没关系没关系
Jake: I didn't record it, it's fine, it's fine.
Lucia:其实那个我不确定
Lucia: Actually, I'm not sure.
Lucia:就是公共场合能不能录
Lucia: If we can record in public.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: OK行行好对
Jake: OK, sure, sure.
Jake: 我来我来我来我来我来
Jake: I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll do it.
Tasha:好了好了己经被我弄下来了
Tasha: Alright, alright, I already got it down.
Jake: 啊什么
Jake: Ah, what?
Jake: XBZ他8点半的
Jake: XBZ at 8:30.
Jake: 8点半到
Jake: 8:30 arrival.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 好伟大啊
Katrina: So great.
Jake: 我刚刚他伟大
Jake: I just said he's great.
Jake: 他过来听他搁那吹牛逼呢
Jake: He came over and started bragging.
Jake: 伟大呵呵
Jake: Great, haha.
Jake: 过来吹牛逼呢好伟大
Jake: Came over bragging, so great.
Jake: 故事的伟大
Jake: Great story.
Tasha: 就非要下着大雨过来找听故事
Tasha: Came over in the pouring rain just to hear the story.
Jake: 这是伟大的故事
Jake: This is a great story.
Jake: great story
Jake: Great story.
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my god
Jake: 牛逼
Jake: Awesome
Jake: 牛啊牛啊
Jake: So cool, so cool
Jake: 取下来了70%
Jake: We've got 70% of it down
Jake: 确实牛批
Jake: Truly awesome
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my god
Jake: 这东西烫烫手
Jake: This thing is hot
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Jake: 人均打车呀
Jake: Everyone takes a cab, right?
Jake: 这可不人均打车
Jake: Isn't everyone taking a cab?
Jake: 除了XBZ坐地铁
Jake: Except XBZ who takes the subway
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 朝阳群众可不一样
Jake: The Chaoyang folks are different
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Alice: 老板有没有觉得心没有那么痛
Alice: Boss, do you feel less heartache?
Jake: 哈哈很开心很开心
Jake: Haha, very happy, very happy
Jake: 他们他们
Jake: They, they
Jake: 他们打哪去了
Jake: Where did they go?
Jake: 他们打北邮去了吗
Jake: Did they go to Beiyou?
Jake: 138
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm
Jake: 我靠这么远
Jake: Wow, that's so far
Jake: 草草莓大学
Jake: Strawberry University
Alice:那就是有的时候碰到
Alice: So sometimes you run into it
Jake: 草莓大学
Jake: Strawberry University
Jake: 嗯那这个挺好
Jake: Yeah, this is good
Alice:中国农业大学
Alice: China Agricultural University
Jake: 为为啥呢
Jake: Why?
Alice:都有
Alice: They have it all
Jake:呵
Jake: Heh
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 就校园
Alice: Just on campus
Alice: 墙上说的比较多的就是的瓜
Alice: 就是不是那种男女的那种
Alice: Not the usual male and female stuff 性别问题
Jake: 成功了嗯
Jake: Success, mm
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Mm
Jake: 啊这个要
Jake: Ah, this needs
Jake: 这个用风吹一吹
Jake: This needs to be aired out
Jake: 这个用风吹一吹能强点
Jake: Airing this out will make it stronger
Alice:所以你用这个吗
Alice: So, are you using this?
Jake: 我们自己就试一点
Jake: We'll just try a bit ourselves.
Jake: 剩下的给XBZ
Jake: The rest goes to XBZ.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 他都没打车
Katrina: He didn't even take a cab.
Jake: 他他坐地铁了
Jake: He took the subway.
Jake: 就是他晚了
Jake: That's why he's late.
Jake: 他已经上地铁了
Jake: He's already on the subway.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 对住住修硕房间
Jake: Yeah, stay in Shure's room.
Lucia: thank you
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake: 你说铲子是吗
Jake: You mean a shovel, right?
Jake: 对有
Jake: Yeah, we have one.
Lucia:啊你没听清我说啥你别乱回啊
Lucia: Ah, you didn't hear me clearly, don't just reply randomly.
Jake:哈哈没没读
Jake: Haha, didn't read it.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:未读就乱回
Lucia: Replying without reading.
Jake: 未未读回一个
Jake: Just reply without reading.
Jake: 好哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, hahaha.
Jake: 未未读给你一个解决方案哈哈哈
Jake: Here's a solution for you, hahaha.
Lucia:不愧是您
Lucia: As expected from you.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 你先吹着
Lucia: You blow on it first.
Lucia: 我去拿门口那个
Lucia: I'll get the one by the door.
Jake: 好好好我吹一吹
Jake: Okay, okay, I'll blow on it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 这我会
Jake: I got this.
Jake: 吹这个事我还是会的
Jake: Blowing on this is something I can do.
Jake: 那个太大了
Jake: That one's too big.
Tasha:这边吹过了吗
Tasha: Did you blow on this side?
Jake: 吹过了
Jake: Yep, I did.
Jake: 哇哦
Jake: Wow.
Jake: 要先放先放这吧
Jake: Let's put it here first.
Jake: 我勒个去
Jake: Oh my goodness.
Jake: 嘘太牛逼了
Lucia:这个胶还算是好的因为它粘和很紧
Lucia: This glue is actually pretty good because it sticks really well.
Jake: 对这胶挺好的
Jake: Yeah, this glue is pretty good.
Jake: 这胶挺贵的
Jake: This glue is quite expensive.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:车来了
Alice: The car’s here.
Alice:准备走了再见准备走了
Alice: Time to go, bye, we’re leaving.
Jake: 欢送
Jake: Farewell.
Alice:走了拜拜
Alice: We're leaving, bye.
Lucia:拜拜
Lucia: Bye.
Alice:真不帮我拉我自己拉
Alice: Really, no help with my luggage? I’ll pull it myself.
刘婷:我还午打伞呢
Liu Ting: I’m still holding an umbrella.
Alice:好好 好
Alice: Okay, okay.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye.
Jake: 拜拜拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye bye bye.
Alice:伞呢
Alice: Where’s the umbrella?
刘婷:包里不用你带
Liu Ting: In the bag, you don’t need to carry it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那个应该很容易最好
Jake: That should be very easy to handle.
Tasha:最好扒啦
Jake: 最好扒
Jake: 5号最好扒
Tasha: 这个涂洗衣液了吗
Tasha: Did you put laundry detergent on this?
Jake: 唉唉唉唉唉唉唉唉唉唉唉
Jake: Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
Jake: 这个涂了
Jake: This one has it.
Jake: 这个涂的可是多
Jake: This one has a lot on it.
Jake: 那个可能没有涂
Jake: That one might not have any.
Jake: 那个是留给XBZ的就是
Jake: That one is saved for XBZ.
Tasha:我们把一楼给清掉
Tasha: Let's clear out the first floor.
Tasha:二楼留给谢彬竹
Tasha: Leave the second floor for Xie Binzhu.
Jake: 哦那那也可以
Jake: Oh, that works too.
Jake: 那我们在二楼听
Jake: We'll listen on the second floor.
Jake: 给给XBZ讲个故事
Jake: Tell XBZ a story.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 都会被她扒干净了
Katrina: She'll clean it all up.
Jake: 哈哈还要停是吧
Jake: Haha, we need to stop, right?
Katrina: 确实
Katrina: Indeed.
Tasha: 他他八卦之心太重了
Tasha: His gossiping heart is too heavy.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哈哈是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Jake: 就跟他讲八卦他发烧能好
Jake: Just tell him gossip and he'll recover from his fever.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: 比头饱管用
Jake: More effective than a headbutt.
Jake: 对啊对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 比头发管用
Jake: More effective than hair.
Jake: 呃这边还有一个
Jake: Uh, there's another one here.
Jake: 一楼有一些失败的
Jake: There are some failed ones on the first floor.
Jake: 这个定位位置就贴了几个
Jake: We just put a few at this location.
Jake: 最后没用
Jake: But it didn't work in the end.
Tasha:这还有一个
Tasha: There's another one here.
Jake: 对是
Jake: Yeah, there is.
Jake: 有有有有有有
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 呃它
Jake: Uh, it...
Jake: 嗯好为它好好的
Jake: Hmm, okay, let's do it well.
Jake: 嗯不太好
Jake: Hmm, not very good.
Jake: 我靠这个能跟它粘住啊真牛逼
Jake: Wow, this can stick to it, really awesome.
Jake: 不不不我拿个凳子就好
Jake: No, no, no, I'll just get a stool.
Tasha:这这这这
Tasha: This, this, this...
Lucia:知道我来的时候忘记带什么
Lucia: You know what I forgot to bring when I came?
Lucia:牢牢手套
Lucia: Sturdy gloves.
Lucia: 就是那种
Lucia: You know, the kind...
Lucia: 对对对哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, haha.
Lucia: 就是每次
Lucia: Every time...
Lucia: 每次你做什么东西之前
Lucia: Every time before you do something,
Lucia:你要先带上这个
Lucia: You need to put these on first.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:什么热胶枪啊的胶
Lucia: For hot glue guns and stuff.
Jake:是挺烫手的这东西
Jake: Yeah, this thing gets pretty hot.